und herren liebe parteifreunde die bloße
tatsache dass wir uns heute hier dass
wir uns heute hier in dresden mit vielen
hundert menschen zu unserem
bundesparteitag versammeln ist in dieser
schlimmen zeit bereits die erste
politische botschaft noch bevor das
erste wort überhaupt gesprochen ist in
zeitlicher abwandlung eines bekannten
schon etwas älteren amerikanischen
popsongs könnte man sagen we do it again
denn dies ist man schon unser zweiter
präsenz parteitag mitten in corona
zeiten und er wird ebenso gut
funktionieren wie der erste
was hat man uns nicht alles vorgeworfen
im vorfeld des parteitages von kalter
unverantwortlich sei das ein super-event
gebe das schlimme folgen für alle werde
das haben und was danach passiert
richtig nichts und so wird es auch
diesmal sein weil wir uns nämlich an die
regeln halten weil wir
eigenverantwortung leben weil wir zeigen
wollen und zeigen dass es geht dass
diese ganzen verbots orgien dieses
einsperren diesen locker und wahnsinn
dass all das nicht braucht wenn man den
menschen vertraut dass sie zur
eigenverantwortung willens und auch
fähig sind
und so sollen unsere wegen union grüne
und all die anderen verbots fanatiker in
diesem land weiter ihre online
parteitage abhalten wir liebe freunde
zeigen mit diesem parteitag erneut dass
es auch anders geht
denn wir das zeigt sich schon in der
botschaft dieser präsenz versammlung
gegen alle widrigkeiten
wir sind eben die alternative für
deutschland und darum ein herzliches
willkommen ihnen allen zum zwölften
bundesparteitag unsere alternative für
deutschland in dresden
meine damen und herren ihre
parteifreunde heute und morgen geht es
um etwas wirklich wichtiges für unsere
partei aber mehr noch für unser land
die einzige echte oppositionspartei in
deutschland wird ihr wahlkampfprogramm
verabschieden und vorstellen gemeinsam
mit unserer wahlkampf konzeption die von
einem wie ich finde so einfach wie
dringend richtungsweisenden titel
getragen wird wir haben das gerade
gesehen deutschland aber noch mal das
wollen wir
und nach lage der dinge sind wir in der
politischen landschaft unseres verrückt
gewordenen landes die einzige kraft die
das noch will normal
normal liebe freunde ist es morgens
aufzustehen und zur arbeit zu gehen und
seinen lebensunterhalt selbst zu
verdienen
normal ist es von seinem selbst
erzielten einkommen auch so viel zur
eigenen verfügung behalten zu dürfen
dass man damit sein leben ohne weitere
staatliche unterstützung bestreiten kann
normal
normal ist dass eine familie aus mutter
vater und kindern besteht und diese das
rückgrat unserer gesellschaft bilden
dass unsere kinder dass unsere kinder
regelmäßig in die schule gehen und dass
sie dort wirkliche bildung genießen und
von ideologischer und sexueller früh
indoktrination unbehelligt gewähren
lassen werden lassen das
dass der staat das gewaltmonopol hat und
überall im land wenn es sein muss auch
robust durchsetzt hat es irgendwelche
clans zu überlassen
normal ist das unser land nach außen
wehrhaft ist mit einem voll
funktionsfähigen militär normal ist dass
unsere verkehrs- energie- und
kommunikationsinfrastruktur modernsten
standards genügt und krisenresistent ist
ließ sich eben für einen der modernsten
industriestaaten der welt gehört und
liebe freunde
normal ist dass die grundrechte der
menschen ganz selbstverständlich gelten
und nicht einzelfall weise vom staat
großzügig gewährt werden
das alles das alles liebe freunde und
noch viel mehr ist eigentlich normal es
sollte so selbstverständlich sein wie
ist dass viele jahrzehnte in der
geschichte unseres wundervollen landes
war sollte ist es aber nicht mehr
denn seit mittlerweile 16 jahren wird
unser land von einer kanzlerin und von
parteien regiert die all diese für das
funktionieren unserer gesellschaft so
immens wichtige normalität schritt für
schritt zerstört haben
darin begleitet von sozialistischen
oppositionsparteien mit den sogenannten
grünen und den linken denen diese
zerstörung sogar noch nicht weit und
nicht schnell genug geht
liebe freunde ist gab einmal einen sehr
einfachen sehr klugen sehr richtigen
wahlkampf slogan der cdu zu zeiten als
diese partei tatsächlich noch eine
konservative grundierung hatte der hieß
ganz einfach
freiheit statt sozialismus und in der
tat
nein
da kriegt die einzige cdu hier sogar mal
applaus wer hätte das gedacht
in der tat das ist auch drei worte
reduziert die entscheidung wie eine jede
gesellschaft für sich treffen muss
denn freiheit und sozialismus sind
vollkommen unvereinbar sozialismus ist
ausnahmslos immer überall absolut
untrennbar und in jeder spielart mit
unfreiheit unterdrückung repression und
ökonomischen niedergang verbunden
es gibt historisch keine ausnahme und
das kann und wird logischerweise auch in
der zukunft keine geben dass sozialismus
stets und ständig gegen das zutiefst
menschliche bedürfnis nach einem
individuellen und selbstbestimmten leben
gerichtet ist eine sehr traurige brannte
an dem alten und richtigen union slogan
ist aus heutiger sicht dass er in seiner
zeitlosigkeit natürlich immer noch
stimmt die union heute aber eben nicht
mehr für freiheit sondern ebenso wie die
spd die grünen wie die linke für
sozialismus steht und dass es frau
merkels katastrophales werk und das
ihrer mitstreiter die nie den mut
aufgebracht haben sich dem handeln
dieser frauen den weg zu stellen
heute
heute steht diese union inzwischen in
freiem fall befindlich und alle
grundsätze entledigt nach jahr in einer
koalition mit einer permanente agonie
befindlichen spd an der schwelle zu
einer koalitionsregierung mit den
sogenannten grünen man kennt sich man
versteht sich in berlin
jeder rechnet damit dass es im herbst
bekommt dabei ist es inzwischen sogar
weit es geht egal ob es schwarz-grün
geräten gibt oder einen grün schwarz die
treibende politische kraft neben uns als
einzige echte opposition in diesem land
sind zum entsetzen aller menschen die zu
vernunft begabt und es sehen es noch
fähig sind die grünen
die union ist nach 16 jahren merkel eher
entkernt skandalgeschüttelte ohne jede
verbliebene substanz und zwar inhaltlich
wie personell
der ton der ton wird also absehbar ab
dem herbst von sozialistischen verbots
und quoten fanatikern angegeben die in
ihrem wahlprogramm offen ankündigen und
das muss man sehen
die grenzen deutschlands für alle
uneingeschränkt öffnen und die schlepper
kriminalität durch legalisierung
entkriminalisieren zu wollen
mit einem spitzen duo indem wir eine
potenzielle kanzlerkandidat ganz
freimütig bekennt dass er mit
deutschland noch nie etwas anzufangen
wusste und vaterlandsliebe schon immer
zum kotzen fand zieht ab robert habeck
und die andere potenzielle
kanzlerkandidaten die möchte strom in
netzen speichern
ein ding der physikalischen
unmöglichkeit wie jeder siebte weiß
nicht habe die fakten befreite anna lena
und die sich daran erfreut dass die
batterien von e autos aus china heute
ganz frei von kobolden sind die menschen
im land brauchen eigentlich nur zwei
wahlprogramm zur bundestagswahl wirklich
zu lesen bevor sie zur wahlurne
schreiten im september nämlich dass der
grünen und dass der alternative für
deutschland die anderen sind irrelevant
schauen sie cdu und spd sind inhalt
nicht so am ende dass sich die befassung
mit deren programm nicht lohnt
die linke die linke propagiert die
üblichen kommunistischen umverteilungs
fantasien und ist sowieso nicht ernst zu
nehmen
die fdp kann sich die abfassung eines
wahlprogramms gleich schenken und ihre
zentrale wahlkampfaussage auf einen
einzigen satz reduzieren
diesmal wollen wir irgendwie mitregieren
egal wie und mit wem
hauptsache wir kriegen ein paar
ministerien und da bleiben eben zwei
parteien die zu beachten sich lohnen die
sogenannten grünen und die alternative
für deutschland das ist die eigentliche
wahl vor der unser land im herbst steht
und das ist nichts anderes als die wahl
zwischen freiheit
dafür stehen wir die afb und sozialismus
da versteht die partei der grünen liebe
freunde das müssen wir deutlich machen
den menschen nahe bringen es ihnen
erklären
und das ist nicht so einfach wie es uns
politisch aufgeklärten menschen scheint
denn die grünen tarnen sich als
vermeintliche ökologen und welt und
klima wetter und seien wir ehrlich die
tun das durchaus geschickt und gerade
derzeit durchaus erfolgreichen wir
müssen diese gezielte verwirrungen der
begriffe durchbrechen und die wahrheit
auch für unpolitische menschen erkennbar
machen die faschisten nennen sich heute
ja auch nicht mehr verschissen
nein sie nennen sich scheinbar
freundlich antifaschisten kurz am tiefer
und so nennen sich die sozialisten heute
eben auch nicht mehr sozialisten sondern
sie nennen sich scheinbar ökologisch
grüne und wir müssen diesen spuk
entlarven bevor es zu spät ist
wir müssen nicht nur heraus stellen
warum wir aus 1001 guten gründen gegen
diesen irrsinn sind sondern es ist
zugleich unsere ungemein wichtige
aufgabe deutlicher als bislang noch auf
zu zeigen wofür wir sind wir stehen mal
etwas salopp gesprochen für schnelltests
wir all die stadt altmaier
dann funktioniert das nämlich wir stehen
für hightech stadt haben und verstehen
für markt statt merkel
und wir tun das aus gutem grund und bei
endlich wenn auch noch zu langsam
erwachen im bewusstsein unseres volkes
die menschen sehen ja inzwischen den
täglich größer werdende zahl das ist ein
hoffnungsschimmer dass wir alle
gemeinsam in haft genommene eines
fundamentalen staatsversagen find die
altmaier spahns merkel sind von der
leyens haben in der größten krise
unseres landes versagt und versagen mit
jedem vergehenden tag nur immer noch
weiter weil sie es nicht können
sie können nicht produktion sie können
nicht gescheiter verträge schließen
sie können nicht logistik noch
distribution wir warten dringend auf die
impfstoffversorgung und verteilung wie
sie in anderen staaten israel die usa
und dann brachte auch dass das aus der
eu ausgetretene großbritannien wie es in
diesen staaten längst realität ist
wir warten darauf mit fatalen
konsequenzen denn das ihn in berlin
allein noch einfällt ist plump und
undifferenzierte lockdown des
öffentlichen lebens mit gigantischen
kollateralschäden ökonomischer sozialer
und psychischer natur für die menschen
unseres landes ein stumpfes weiter so wo
andere längst überzeugendere und bessere
antworten auf die krise gefunden haben
liebe freunde was sie uns schon viel zu
lange regierenden hier herum wurschteln
und was die grünen vielleicht mit der
möglichen ausnahme des boris palmer
sogar noch verschärfen wollen
das ist unseres landes schlicht unwürdig
und das führt uns schnurstracks und
offenbar unbilden eine katastrophe
hinein ökonomisch sozial und es gibt in
diesem land zu diesem hier sehen nur
eine alternative und diese nach lage der
dinge wir die afd
da haben wiederhole ich heute ein
weiteres mal was ich schon auf dem
bundesparteitag in braunschweig und
danach noch manchmal gesagt habe wir
müssen bereit sein verantwortung zu
übernehmen
die anderen versagen allesamt es kommt
auf uns zu unweigerlich wir müssen es
nur richtig machen unsere überlegenen
lösungen die wir haben anbieten
aufzeigen erklären
sachlich unbeirrbar fest und hart in der
sache verbindlich im ton
das ist uns aufgetragen und die
verantwortung die wir als alternative
tragen ist enorm
nehmen wir sie an liebe freunde ich
komme zum ende meiner kurzen
grußbotschaft
ich möchte das jedoch nicht tun ohne
entschieden auf etwas aufmerksam zu
machen was wir selbst am herzen liegt
und was bei der ganzen fokussierung auf
die bundestagswahl leicht unterzugehen
droht das sind ja noch mehr ganz
wichtige wahlen in diesem jahr
landtagswahlen in einer ganzen reihe von
bundesländern nämlich und ohne die
anderen länder in denen wahlen sind
missachten zu wollen eine jede dieser
wahlen ist von eigener großer
wichtigkeit gar keine frage
aber ich möchte jedoch eine
bevorstehende landtagswahl besonders
hervorheben
das ist die nächste
die am 6 juni in sachsen anhalt
stattfinden wird sie ist von
außergewöhnlicher bedeutung und der
sollten wir alle gemeinsam alles
mögliche dafür tun dass sie zu einem
vollen erfolg für uns wird natürlich hat
diese landtagswahl als letzte vor der
bundestagswahl signalcharakter für die
bundestagswahl im september
aber es ist ein anderer noch wichtigerer
grund denn hier herausstellen möchte
wir haben wenn wir es richtig angehen
bei dieser wahl die große chance
erstmals und sogar mit beträchtlichem
abstand zur stärksten politischen kraft
in einem bundesland zu werden
neueste neueste umfragen weisen sogar
die 3 vorne
als dann durchaus im bereich des
möglichen liegen das resultat aus wir
liegen derzeit runde 10 bis 11
prozentpunkte vor den nächstplatzierten
partei dass diese partei im niedergang
noch gleich richtig cdu damit mit diesem
regierungsauftrag ging dann also oder
mit diesem wahlsieg den ich sehr der da
drin ist dinge dann erstmals in der
geschichte unserer partei
der auftrag zu einer regierungsbildung
einher und eine regierungsbildung ohne
uns ginge wohl nur in einer mit recht
als absurd anmutenden vier parteien
konstellation von cdu bis linke kurzum
maximaler einsatz der partei für den
landtagswahlkampf in sachsen-anhalt
lohnt sich besonders unterstützen wir in
den kommenden zwei monaten
unterstützen wir den kommenden zwei
monaten neben dem einsetzenden
bundestagswahlkampf mit voller kraft
unserer parteifreunde in magdeburg
zeigen wir von dort aus geht auf was für
uns möglich ist
liebe freunde nehmen wir diesen dresdner
parteitag als signal geschlossen in
diese wahlkämpfe zu ziehen
deutschland ist unter merkel zu einem
land geworden dass in der welt kaum mehr
jemand ernst nimmt lebt jetzt in brüssel
jeden tag ein land das immer verrückter
wird ein land in dem die leider noch
führenden politiker sich inzwischen
sinnfrei stammelt als politiker innen
bezeichnen und von unseren kinder im
kindergartenalter mit absurden
ideologien überzogen werden
statt eine von solchem unnormalen unfug
unbelastete und freie kindheit haben zu
dürfen wie wir das glück hatten sie zu
erleben
holen wir uns in diesen wahlen unser
land zurück unser land sowie hier und
viele millionen menschen es kennen und
wieder haben wollen
deutschland aber normal
dankeschön
[Applaus]